if you traveled 250 million years into
the past you'd be witnessing the dawn of
Dinosaurs one of the leading theories is
that dinosaurs evolved from a species
known as archosaurs these were the
dominant reptiles that appeared during
the late perian period to some they may
even look like dinosaurs and that's
because they were ancestors to these
incredible creatures over time the
archosaurs split up into two groups one
of these groups led to crocodiles and
the other led to dinosaurs which
continued evolving into thousands of
different species one of the main traits
they eventually gained was their bipedal
abilities early dinosaurs began to walk
on two legs freeing their front limbs
for other uses like grabbing food and
defending themselves and that's just the
start of their evolutionary Journey
let's travel back in time 200 50 million
years ago and witness the history of
dinosaurs in 10
minutes Triassic
period as you enter this new era you'll
notice that the dinosaurs running around
look pretty different from what you're
used to seeing one of the earliest
dinosaurs that emerged from the
archosaurs was the Eoraptor this little
guy was about the size of a dog barely 1
M tall and weighing in at a meager 10 kg
you know we typically think of dinosaurs
as the these massive creatures but it'
be a couple million more years before
that started to happen we'll check in to
see how those dinos are growing in size
as we travel through time but for now
let's see what's happening to Earth
during the Triassic period the
supercontinent Pangia starts to fragment
slowly altering Global climates and
ecosystems the climate was generally hot
and dry and there were no polar ice caps
creating a stark contrast to what you're
typically used to in modern day Earth
the vegetation was also very different
and was crucial for the survival and
evolution of dinosaurs the plants have
different characteristics as well some
are tough some nutritious and others
potentially poisonous each one of them
will influence the dietary and adaptive
strategies of different dinosaur species
speaking of which what are some other
dinosaurs doing during this time
weighing in at about 23 kg and 1 M tall
we have the celop fisis it was a little
bit bigger than the Eoraptor but that
didn't stop it from being a fast and
agile Predator that likely prayed on
smaller animals now the herrerasaurus
was slightly taller at about 1.1 M but
was a lot heavier at about 350
kg then we have the plateosaurus now
this guy is way bigger than me it stood
tall at about 3 m and weighed up to
4,000 kg this was one of the earliest
examples of how big dinosaurs could grow
but wait they get even bigger than this
despite their impressive forms dinosaurs
weren't the dominant creatures during
the Triassic they had to share their
environments with many other organisms
all vying for survival in the diverse
ecosystems this was the case until the
Triassic period would experience a great
Extinction event
this was likely caused by Massive
volcanic activity climate change and
potentially even some small asteroid
impacts this will have a significant
effect on life on Earth and lead to the
extinction of numerous species but it
wasn't all bad especially for our
dinosaurs this moment set the stage to
bring new opportunities to these species
leading to them dominating the
Earth Jurassic Period
now instead of dinosaurs simply
surviving this is where they
Thrive over the millions of years
different species have been evolving and
dinosaurs are now the rulers of the
earth they spread across continents
dominating the Lush forests and arid
deserts occupying these areas were some
massive dinosaurs ones that you're
probably a lot more familiar with we
have the stegosaurus brachiosaurus and
Al osaurus these were some of the
largest creatures ever to walk the earth
but you'd quickly notice that it wasn't
just these massive beasts that were
roaming around this era also saw the
evolution of
theropods these were smaller dinosaurs
that had more of a birdlike form one of
the most famous was the archaeopteris it
was kind of like a mix between a
dinosaur and a bird with feathers and
wings but also with bony teeth and a
tail the archaeopteris was a crucial
link between birds and dinosaurs if you
wait about 100 million more years
they'll evolve into the birds we know
today oh wait is that a
spoiler after 56 million years the
Jurassic period comes to an end this was
after yet another Extinction event
happened luckily this one is more minor
however due to climate change volcanic
activity and sea levels changing some
species are going
extinct this once again changes the
landscape as the dinosaurs enter their
final
era Cretaceous
Period okay we've now entered the
Cretaceous Period and as we've been
traveling through these millions of
years you may have noticed something's
missing right one of the dinosaurs
biggest stars hasn't appeared yet say
hello to the Tyrannosaurus Rex
the T-Rex was a massive Beast it was 3.7
M tall and 12 M long not only that but
it was a whopping nine
tons equipped with a powerful jaw and
Incredibly sharp teeth the T-Rex
dominated the Cretaceous
Kingdom it was one of the most dominant
Predators history has ever seen this
colossal Beast wasn't just Scavenging
leftovers it was an active Hunter
stalking its prey with Keen eyesight and
a heightened sense of smell among its
favorite meals were the sizable
herbivores like the
Edmontosaurus but the T-Rex didn't stop
there it would take on formidable
opponents like the Triceratops and even
other smaller theropods if the
opportunity arose with its powerful jaws
filled with 12in teeth and its strong
hind limbs that allowed it to run at
speeds of of up to 40 kmph the T-Rex was
a master of the hunt but this period
wasn't just filled with massive beasts
like the
T-Rex look around and you'll also notice
even more feathered dinosaurs in the
Cretaceous Period one of them being the
Velociraptor now you typically see them
portrayed like this with no feathers but
evidence suggests that these creatures
were quite feathered now the feathers
weren't necessarily used for flying more
for warmth and ability and this one is
the micro Raptor now unlike the
Velociraptor its feathers likely were
used for flight giving us crucial
insight into the evolution of birds okay
as I mentioned earlier Pangia was
breaking up and forming into the
continents we know today but because of
this some dinosaurs were forced to
migrate and separate into different
areas of the world these dinosaurs had
to adapt to their new environments
potentially changing the course of their
evolution
but none of this matters when we
consider what happens
next the cataclysmic
event okay as you've been hanging out
with the dinosaurs for millions of years
an asteroid has been making its way
toward Earth then suddenly it
hits creating a massive crater 150 km
wide and 20 km
deep naturally something this huge makes
a devastating impact on the world one
that'll change it
forever the asteroids Collision is
massive but its impact is felt long
after the initial crash due to the
massive Collision the environment
drastically changes significant drops in
temperature start to occur and debris
from the crash begins to block out the
sun this impacts not only the dinosaurs
Health but also their food supply this
devastating ating event wipes out
75% of the Earth's species many of which
are the dinosaurs we've been observing
this whole time but don't worry not all
of the dinosaurs went extinct the
aviation-based dinosaurs we checked out
earlier managed to survive the asteroid
strike eventually evolving into
Birds
aftermath now that most of the dinosaurs
are extinct it's cleared the way for
mammals to diversify and expand their
impact on the world with less
competition early mammals can now Thrive
and take over which slowly over time
allowed humans to evolve building the
world we know today dinosaurs went on to
evolve for another 165 million years but
there's still so much we need to learn
about them like did you know that not
all dinosaurs were coldblooded some of
them may have been warm-blooded or even
both but that's a story for another what
if